>> Geraldo: THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA, THE BROADCAST NETWORKS,
STAND ACCUSED OF GASLIGHTING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT'S DISTRACTING US FROM WHAT
REALLY IS THE COUNTRY.
MSNBC'S CHUCK TODD IS ONE OF
THOSE TRYING TO CHANGE THE
SUBJECT, MAKING THE OUTRAGEOUS
CLAIM THAT LIBERAL BIAS DOES NOT
EXIST.
>> WHERE WE DID GET LOST IN
THIS, THE SORT OF HAPPENED TO
MAINSTREAM MEDIA IN PARTICULAR,
IS THAT WE DID LET REPUBLICAN
CRITICS GET IN OUR HEADS.
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN RUNNING ON
THAT THERE'S A LIBERAL BIAS IN
THE MEDIA.
WE SHOULDN'T ACCEPT THE PREMISE
THAT THERE WAS LIBERAL BIAS.
>> Geraldo: KATIE, HOW CAN HE
CLAIM WITH A STRAIGHT FACE THAT
THERE ISN'T A QUESTION MARK
>> Katie: HE'S IN A LIBERAL
BUBBLE SO HE CAN'T SEE OR
LOOK IN THE MIRROR AND SEE
EVERYTHING THAT'S HAPPENED.
7% OF REPORTERS
ACROSS THE ENTIRE COUNTRY
IDENTIFIES REPUBLICANS.
I'VE NEVER SEEN A RIGHTLY NAMED
COMEDIAN INVITED TO THE
WHITE HOUSE PRESS CORPS DINNER,
THE CORRESPONDENTS ASSOCIATION
DINNER.
DANA HAS A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
WITH LIBERAL MEDIA BIAS,
DEFENDING A REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PERCENTAGES
OF POSITIVE COVERAGE FOR
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENTS OR
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTS, AND JUST
THE TYPES OF QUESTIONS THAT ARE
ASKED, THAT THERE WERE NO
SCANDALS WHEN THEY WERE PLENTY
OF SCANDALS, THE LIST GOES ON
AND ON.
CHUCK TODD'S COMMENTS ARE A
PERFECT REFLECTION OF LIBERAL
MEDIA LIVING IN A LIBERAL MEDIA
BUBBLE.
NO SELF-REFLECTION.
>> Geraldo: THEN WHERE DO YOU
GO FOR YOUR NEWS?
>> Katie: FOX NEWS EN
TownHall.com.
>> Geraldo: WHAT ABOUT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES"?
>> Katie: TOLD ME NOT TO TRUST
"THE NEW YORK TIMES"!
AND I TRUST YOU, GERALDO PAY
[LAUGHTER]
>> Geraldo: YOU ARE A CONSUMER
OF NEWS, YOU HEAR CHUCK TODD'S
THING THERE IS NO LIBERAL BIAS,
GIVE ME A QUANTITY PERCENTAGE OF
LIBERAL TO CONSERVATIVE BIASES.
>> Jesse: UNSCIENTIFICALLY I
WOULD SAY 95%.
I THINK THAT'S ABOUT RIGHT,
UNSCIENTIFICALLY.
I THINK HE'S GOING THROUGH A
MIDLIFE CRISIS.
SOMETHING I'M FAMILIAR WITH.
>> Geraldo: I THOUGHT YOURS
WAS OVER!
>> Jesse: THANKFULLY.
REMEMBER TIM RUSSERT HAD ME
SUPPRESS -- 4 MILLION WATCHING
ON SUNDAY.
NOW CHUCK HAS IT, BARELY
2 MILLION IN THIRD PLACE.
AND HIS SHOW ON MSNBC, IT BARELY
GET 700,000 PEOPLE, OKAY?
THEY HAD TO BUMP IT BECAUSE IT
WAS SO POORLY RATED.
IT IS RANKED 30TH, GERALDO.
HE'S LOSING THE PEOPLE I'VE
NEVER HEARD OF.
HE'S LOSING TO A GUY ON MSNBC
NAMED AYMAN MOHYELDIN, SOMEONE
I'VE NEVER HEARD OF.
HE STRUGGLING TO UNDERSTAND WHY
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE HIM.
HE'S BLAMING OTHER PEOPLE.
YOU DON'T LIKE YOU BECAUSE YOU
DON'T TRUST HIM, BECAUSE HE WAS
WRONG ON DONALD TRUMP IN 2016,
ROUND ON RUSSIA, IRAN ON THE
BORDER, SO WHEN HE SAYS THERE IS
NO LIBERAL MEDIA BIAS, THAT'S
HOW I KNOW HE IS BIASED.
HE JUST ADMITTED IT, HE WOULD
PLAY IT STRAIGHT.
>> Geraldo: THAT'S EVEN MORE
GLARING THAN THE RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
>> Dana: I THINK ALSO HOW THE
MEDIA LOCKED ARMS TO PROTECT
HUNTER BIDEN FROM GETTING
COVERAGE.
BUT I ALSO THINK THESE VOTING
RIGHTS BILLS THAT ARE HAPPENING
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, THERE IS A
REALLY INTERESTING TEST YOU CAN
DO.
THERE IS ONE BROADCAST NETWORK I
WATCH EVERY SINGLE NIGHT, I'VE
GOT TO SAY, ON THE VOTING ISSUE,
IT HAS BEEN UNBELIEVABLY BAD.
TERRIBLY BAD.
>> Greg: I'M GUESSING
ABC NEWS.
>> Dana: YOU KNOW WHO I LIKE.
[LAUGHTER]
FIRST OF ALL, THEY ALMOST NEVER
QUOTE A SINGLE REPUBLICAN OR
CONSERVATIVE EVER.
THEY ALSO BASICALLY NEVER
MENTION ANYTHING THAT PEOPLE
VOTING AGAINST THESE BILLS WOULD
BE OPPOSED TO.
THEY DON'T EVEN MENTION IT.
FOR EXAMPLE, HR ONE WOULD HAVE
ENDED VOTER I.D.
THEY DON'T MENTION IT.
THEY USE ALL THE LEFT'S TERMS,
LIKE RESTRICTIONS RATHER THAN
DEATH REFORM.
IT IS RESTRICTION, SUPPRESSION.
AND THEY NEVER CITE THEIR
SOURCES.
SO THEY DON'T SAY, "THIS CAME
FROM THE BRENNAN CENTER."
WELL, WHO FUNDS THE BRENNAN
CENTER?"
YOUR FAVORITE PAY
[LAUGHTER]
>> Geraldo: YOU HAVE TO GET
THE NEWS IT FROM ONE PLACE, HE
CAN'T WATCH ONE NETWORK ALL DAY
LONG.
WHAT DO YOU DO?
YOU HAVE TO READ A NEWSPAPER.
>> Greg: I THINK YOU WATCH THE
STUFF THAT IS CORRECTLY LABELED.
FOX NEWS, YOU KNOW IT'S NEWS AND
COMMENTARY.
YOU KNOW IT "THE FIVE."
MAYBE IT'S TIME TO "CHUCK" TODD.
THE REASON WE GET IN THEIR
HEADS, BY THE WAY, IS THERE'S
LOTS OF ROOM.
THE PEOPLE ON CNN AND MSNBC
DON'T LABEL THEMSELVES AND THEY
ARE COMMENTATING.
HE IS SUPPOSED TO BE A NEWS GUY,
RIGHT?
BUT HE SAYS THINGS THAT ARE
CLEARLY OPINION.
>> Geraldo: DON'T YOU THINK
THEY BELIEVE WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING?
>> Greg: THERE PROBABLY IN
DENIAL.
IT'S WEIRD, I KIND OF ENJOY
THIS.
BECAUSE THE FACTS DISPUTE
EVERYTHING HE SAYS, AND I THINK
HE JUST -- IT'S LIKE WHEN PEOPLE
SAY, "YOU'RE RACIST," AND THEY
GO, "NO, I'M NOT," AND THEY GO,
"THAT'S PROOF."
"I'M NOT BIASED!"
"THAT'S KIND OF EVIDENC